Hey out there.
Welcome,
welcome,
welcome to another edition of Market Takes.
I know you could have been anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me.
I want to say thank you for that.
I'm your host,
Dion Raboin reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Before we jump into today's C P I inflation report.
I just want to make a real quick announcement.
We are supporting our colleague,
Evan Gko,
which he has been detained in Russia.
The hashtag is I stand with Evan if you don't know now,
you know,
please,
if you haven't looked in that,
check that out,
do some research.
We're spreading the word trying to get awareness out about our colleague who has been detained in Russia.
So I want to make sure I spoke to that this morning because that is a lot bigger than a lot of what we're
doing.
But of course,
I know you're here for the data.
So we are going to dig into that.
Listen,
we are talking about everything from this morning's Consumer Price Index Report.
It is moving the markets this morning and I think could potentially move the markets going forward.
I'm going to tell you just why that is.
So we're going to talk about what we saw in that report.
Of course,
the expectation coming in how today's report really aligned with and some
of the differences and some of the interesting wrinkles within the report today,
we're going to talk about,
of course,
the market reaction,
we've got a new tool.
We're going to be able to show you how markets are reacting almost in real time.
We've got about a 15 minute delay on that,
but you'll be able to see the reaction from this report that came out this morning at 8 30 to
right about now as we're dropping market takes here at 10 AM Eastern time.
Of course,
we're going to talk about the current environment surrounding these reports because of,
of course,
we know that this report C P I and others don't just come out in a vacuum and then of course,
we'll be talking through what comes next.
So we're going to get into all that first off the C P I report this morning showed
headline CPI or overall C P I rising at a 5% rate.
So what you're seeing there on your screen is the year over year change in the CPI.
Now you see starting in April of 2022 it picks up there.
That was when we were seeing that 40 year high inflation in June the third bar there on your,
that's 9.1% inflation,
the highest we had seen since the early 19 eighties.
And then you see that just consistent move lower over those following months.
Now,
what's really interesting about today's report is the actual month,
over month inflation only picked up 190.1%.
And that was actually 0.5% or sorry,
0.5% increase.
So really close to no inflation increase overall in the month.
Um that compared to expectations for it to fall to five 0.1% year over year.
And that was down from the previous month when it was 6%.
You see there in February and then 6.4% you see there in January.
So a kind of precipitous continual decline and decrease in the year over
year pace of inflation according to the CPI.
Now,
I want to contrast that with what we've seen from core CPI and that's an important
indicator because it strips out volatile food and energy prices to give you more
of a look at what the fed can control.
One of the things that the Federal Reserve watches in terms of when they're looking at the market.
So I want to put up here the C P I core uh chart and as you see the,
the numbers don't go up as high,
it remains around 6%.
But then we still have seen since late last year,
early in uh since about mid year in 2022 that those numbers kind of
consistently coming down until you see that last bar there C P I core picked
up by 5.6% last month.
That was the first increase we had actually seen in the CPI core since September.
And actually CPI core was 0.4% month over month.
So again,
a bit of a worrisome trend here where you see consistently inflation has been falling,
declining,
declining overall and that continued.
But core prices stripping out again,
food and energy prices which move significantly taking those out,
you see it picked up.
So again,
just wanted to illustrate what we've seen long term and the differences between that CPI core
report and the overall CPI report C P is doing what the Fed wants it to do.
Just come down,
come down,
decrease till it gets to that 2% target core C P I though this month
bucking that trend a little bit.
And that's interesting.
Now,
why do we talk about core C P I?
Why does it matter?
Well,
because it strips out those volatile pieces and things that the fed really can't control fed doesn't have a lot of
control over oil prices.
The Federal Reserve doesn't really have a lot of control about food prices.
A lot of that's based on commodities,
how they're trading on the open market,
what the fed can control by raising interest,
interest rate is controlling how people are hiring,
whether they're giving raises things like that because when markets get tight businesses can't
borrow,
they can't afford to,
you know,
increase the size of their business as much.
Consumers can't afford to,
you know,
really take out those loans against their homes,
things like that.
And so it slows down the economy.
And when core prices rise as they did in March,
you start to see that be a little worrisome for the Fed.
And that's why,
you know,
the fed thinks of core C P as a better predictor for the future pace of
inflation.
And even though we have seen overall,
generally the C P I come down,
we did see that core pick up this month.
So that's why there might be a little bit of consternation in the markets this morning
getting into the weeds just a little bit.
I want,
I want to get into here because I know that's what y'all like you like when we get a little nerdy and we talk about the
details,
the shelter prices were lower than they've been in about six or seven months.
You had a 70.6% increase month,
over month down from 0.8% in February.
All that means.
And here's why that's big.
I want to read you a quote directly from the B L S S C P I report this morning
quote.
The shelter index was the dominant factor in the monthly increase in the index for all items,
less food and energy.
Basically what that means is that core index that you saw pick up the biggest piece that was shelter.
Now,
why does that matter?
Because our real time data has shown us that increases in rent are declining that the
pace of rent inflation overall,
uh housing price inflation has slowed down.
The FED has seen this.
They've talked about it said we know those are coming down.
That is a lagging indicator in the C P I report and the fed and other economists have
talked about.
Well,
C P I is most of the thing that's holding inflation up and it's most of the thing that's holding core prices up,
that's going to go away as the new data starts to get factored in.
We don't know when that will happen because C P I or I'm sorry,
B L S does not have an exact methodology for when they include changes in
shelter prices.
We know most people sign a new lease in January and then they stay where they are and that's how it happens,
but it doesn't get factored into the data immediately.
And so that's a piece that as soon as that shelter piece starts,
stops rising as fast.
And that's what it appears that we're seeing once that starts happening,
inflation overall could start to drop pretty dramatically and pretty significantly.
That would turn the fed from this very aggressive stance that it's taken to maybe more of a
hands off stance on the market.
And that's a good thing for the overall pace of the economy on the other side.
You know,
we've always got it on the one hand,
on the other hand,
now,
one big part of the decline that we've seen in overall the energy component or the energy index fall by
3.5% overall.
And you saw gasoline,
the gasoline index down 4.6% from the previous month.
That's just month,
over month after rising for the prior two months overall year,
over year,
gasoline was down 17.2%.
What we contrast that with what we've seen from oil prices and want to put something up here on
your screen really quickly to show you.
Boom.
You see overall now in 2022 you see as inflation was rising
as C P I was rising,
you see those gas prices rising,
right?
And then the same thing that you saw with C P I going down down down consistently.
You're seeing oil prices there on your screen as we get into 2023.
Now as you get to where we are right now in a,
you're seeing oil prices start to pick back up.
Now that could mean that you start to see some of these indexes within C P I pick back up as
oil prices go back up.
That also has a big impact on consumer sentiment and how folks feel about inflation,
their inflation expectations.
So that charge is really illustrating the overall trend,
how oil and inflation have really moved in lockstep and we are starting to see
oil prices start to pick back up again.
We're also seeing this at the pump just when you go to fill up your gas tank.
We have seen the average price for a gallon of gas price at 3 62 a gallon up from about 3
32 in December.
So we're seeing a consistent pick up in gas prices out in California,
we're seeing about $5 a gallon almost on gas prices.
This is a sort of worrisome trend that's working in the of what the fed wants.
And we could see,
we saw that gas price cut or that oil,
oil output cut announced by OPEC,
the organization of the petroleum exporting countries.
They announced they're cutting supply.
We know when supply declines demand stays the same prices go up.
So keep your eye on that.
Oil prices are going to be important to watch.
Um,
wanna put something new up here on your screen here and that's going to show you what's happening live in
the markets right now.
So as we look out here on W S J dot com,
you see the dow,
the NASDAQ,
the S and P all rising higher,
but each one especially the NASDAQ coming down and you're seeing prices start to kind of pick back
up,
but this is a bit of the tug of war that you're seeing in the markets want to throw up here really quickly
show you what's happening with bonds.
You see the 10 year note,
it's down in yield by about 3.3% or 3.3 basis points,
excuse me to about 3.4%.
The biggest move that we saw in the,
in the market after the of this report was in the three year and the two year you've seen
the two year that that is kind of come back from that big decline that it took after the report.
But markets basically telling you with this,
that they see the fed having to do less rate hikes,
maybe doing some rate cuts.
We've seen that in the fed funds futures market.
The market really saying this report indicates the fed can pump the brakes on pumping the
brakes,
stop,
stop cutting rates or stop raising rates as much.
And the market is even pricing in some rate cuts through the end of this year.
The market expects the fed to raise rates once in May and then cut them three times after
that.
Very interesting from the market really quickly.
Want to show you what we're seeing from crude oil.
Now,
this is also important because when we see Brent crude and when we see W T I crude boom,
you're seeing a big pick up there.
You can see this just right after the reporters release jump higher in oil prices.
That's because they're expecting more growth,
the fed to have to do less.
And you're seeing that response almost immediately from oil prices.
So this really the markets illustrating what we're seeing in terms of the market reaction and how
investors are reading the C P I report that we got out this morning.
Very interesting what we're seeing there.
Um Let's talk about right now,
step back for a quick second and talk about the current environment.
What we've seen coming into this report,
there has been a lot less talk about inflation.
Folks are just kind of assuming,
hey,
inflation is going to come down.
It's going to keep doing what it's been doing.
This report offered some,
some evidence that that is happening.
Inflation is clearly coming down.
The Fed's processes are working,
but there are still some things to keep your eyes on and we've seen a lot less worry about inflation
recently.
Um There was however a somewhat of a
monkey wrench in that thesis we have seen just yesterday.
The New York Fed survey of households showed that households are projecting one year ahead
inflation to be 4.7%.
That is an increase from 4.2% in February.
The first increase in you had inflation expectations since October.
So a big part of inflation is what people expect to happen.
People expect inflation to fall so they don't demand higher prices or they don't demand higher
wages,
they don't demand a big raise.
They don't demand to be paid more because they don't see prices rising on everything around them.
Inflation expectations also tell people,
oh,
well,
this thing is priced higher.
I'm not going to buy it and I'm not going to pay that higher price.
I'd rather just not pay not buy this item or buy a lower price item that also helps bring
inflation down.
So inflation expectations for the year ahead rising for the first time since
October last month in the Feds in the New York fed survey of households year
inflation expectations also picked up and but five year inflation expectations
decreased a little bit to 2.5% much close to the Fed's 2% target.
The FED has to be a little concerned about the results of that survey yesterday because
you know,
that is something that has a big effect on inflation expectations and the Feds got to manage those
one other note from that fed survey,
Americans said that access the credit was at its toughest level in nearly a decade.
That's definitely something to keep your eye on small businesses and consumers are having a tough
time getting access to credit banks are pulling back on lending,
pulling back on on granting credit.
We've seen that in a lot of the data and that has just been reinforced by this New York Fed
survey,
Black Rock Pimco and some others are starting to warn more seriously about recession risks
and that ties to this lending and this credit,
a lot of folks have kind of run out of money,
those savings that they built up during the pandemic have sort of run dry and now they're
using credit cards,
personal loans,
things like that.
Small businesses are having to draw on credit lines and we're seeing that access to that is getting a
lot harder to come by and that is generally a good precursor for recession.
So definitely keep your eye on that.
Check out those Black Rock and those pimco reports about recession risk,
they say that they expect the Federal Reserve to keep interest rates high even as inflation starts
to kind of come down even with what we've seen today on C P I.
And that could lead to a likely recession.
That's what some of those professional asset managers are talking about.
Fed speakers over the past couple of weeks have really studied this.
They've said we are likely to raise rates in May keep your eye on that
fed President or sorry fed President Loretta Mester,
as well as ST Louis Fed,
President Bullard both railed in and came in and said this,
we expect to keep rates high.
So that may just be for May.
That's how the markets are assuming they're saying,
hey,
fed is going to raise rates in May,
then they're going to cut.
That's a big part of the market narrative and the increases in stock prices that we've seen
lately.
We're seeing a kind of theme of the markets versus the fed,
the markets.
Not believing the Fed is going to do what they say they're going to do.
Keep your eye on that.
That's a big theme moving forward.
Listen,
here's what comes next.
We get the P P I report the producer price index that's on Thursday,
that's expected to fall to 4.4%.
We've seen P P I lead C P I.
And so if P P I comes in as expected,
that's a good sign,
especially given the lower than expected C P I report we got today a good sign that
inflation is moderating going away.
That's more good news.
Keep that,
keep that on your radar.
We also get retail sales.
The retail sales report is out Friday.
It's going to show us what people are,
people are buying what they're not.
Bank earnings is out on Friday.
Bank earnings are out.
I should say the big boys city Wells,
Fargo JP,
Morgan Chase,
they'll all be reporting on Friday.
We're going to learn a lot about the economy from that.
And so we will be here on Monday talking about what we learned from the bank earnings reports and everything we got last
week and we'll be looking ahead to next week.
I hope you'll join us on market takes on Monday.
We'll be talking about the N H B market housing market index as well.
As housing starts,
the Fed's Beige Book and Us Manufacturing and Services P P I S.
We will be getting into all of that.
Listen,
that's gonna do it for us here on Market takes,
I'm your host,
Dion Rabo Reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Thank you so much for being with us and we will see you next time.